hey guys I just wanted to say thank you
so much for 7 million subscribers I
don't have time for a long video because
I'm about to head out to the airport but
it's just been a really weird we can
have with the random almost dying
hospital trip and all that but I just
wanted to say thank you to my family
this is my mom here who's never been in
a video and has been very shy and
hesitant to be on this one and my
brother is holding the camera up there
and all the doggies here I just elbow
Charlie in the face so sorry but just
wanted to say thank you guys so much for
bearing with me during this time or I
haven't been able to make videos and
it's been really good for me to be home
again because it made me realize how
much I missed all this but I don't have
a lot of time so just thank you so much
and I know there's gonna be a lot of
creations coming out today from the fan
community and whatnot
and just thank you guys so much I'll be
checking it out while I'm on the plane
and Lucchese gonna miss me gucchi Lucy
haha maybe when it gets with me dokie
okay good you have it not my crotch
don't sniff my crotch that's not what I
want Lucy get up Lucy pom pom yeah oh
you're a big dog yeah alright
everything's gone out of control but
blah say bye Thompson's alright